the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we're still on story board 7
we're on panels see candle see is where
I introduced the TCA cycle as I
mentioned earlier respiration consists
of three stages the first is the
pyruvate dehydrogenase reaction which we
just covered taking pyruvate to acetyl
co a the second is the TCA cycle or
tricarboxylic acid cycle taking that
acetyl co a and basically oxidizing it
in order to generate co2 but also to
produce more reducing equivalents in the
form of mobile electron carriers and
then the third step of respiration is
taking those reducing equivalents to the
mitochondrial inner membrane with the
molecules containing those reducing
equivalents are oxidized and then the
electrons from that oxidation reaction
are used to power proton pumps that
ultimately will generate the proton
gradient that can be used for generation
of ATP or for generation of movement or
for other things the tricarboxylic acid
cycle which is sometimes called the
krebs cycle takes acetyl co way from
several different sources one of those
sources is glycolysis to pyruvate and
pyruvate to acetyl co way as we've just
seen and the second source of acetyl co
a is from fatty acid oxidation will come
to that pathway somewhat later
again looking at panels see the TCA
cycle starts with the reaction of acetyl
coenzyme a a two carbon compound with
oxaloacetate a four carbon compound to
form the six carbon product citrate
citrate will lose two carbons as carbon
dioxide and in the process there'll be a
series of oxidation steps that generate
three NADH --is one fadh2 and one either
GTP or ATP by substrate level
phosphorylation in terms of the banking
system of the cell the NADH s that are
generated in
mitochondria are exchangeable for about
three atps fadh2 is exchangeable for
about two ATP's so if you look up the
total number of nucleotide triphosphate
or NTP equivalents that can be produced
in the TCA cycle you'll get about twelve
atps for each to carbon unit of acetic
away that's oxidized as a detail point I
want to mention that the two carbons
that entered the TCA cycle as acetic
away are not exactly the same two
carbons that come out as co2 in that
cycle the carbon dioxides from the input
acetyl co a will emerge in later terms
of the TCA cycle now we're going to look
at panel D in penalty we start looking
at the details of the TCA cycle Joanne
explained why nature uses thio esters
the sulfur allows enol ization
stabilization of our carbon ion a carbon
to the carbon that's distal to the
coenzyme a functionality the carbon
anion is then able to attack the number
two carbon carbonyl of oxaloacetate in
the reaction catalyzed by citrate
synthase an intermediate is formed
suture wheel coenzyme a which loses its
coenzyme a moiety by hydrolysis in a
very thermodynamically irreversible step
resulting in the product citrate this
step is at the top of the pathway and as
is usually the case this highly
exothermic step makes the pathway
overall irreversible chemically citrate
synthase does a mixed aldol clays and
ester consultation the product of the
citrate synthase reactions citrate is a
tertiary alcohol and tertiary alcohols
are relatively difficult to oxidize the
next enzyme in the pathway econo tazed
which is shown in storyboard eight panel
a removes the water molecule and then
adds a different water molecule back to
rearrange the hydroxyl group making a
secondary alcohol which is much easier
to oxidize looking again at panel a the
hydroxyl group of height isocitrate is
oxidized to a ketone with the transfer
of hydride to nad plus to make NADH this
reaction is catalyzed by the enzyme
isocitrate dehydrogenase ice
th-the intermediate in this reaction is
ox a low suction aid which is a beta
keto acid as we know from what Joanne
taught us beta keto acids are prone to
spontaneous decarboxylation so the
second half of the isocitrate
dehydrogenase reaction involves the loss
of carbon dioxide in what's usually
considered to be an irreversible step I
do want to point out however that under
certain circumstances you can re-add the
carbon dioxide in order to make the
reaction go in the other direction
after the ice EDH reactions which
generated nadh resulted in loss of co2
the product is alpha ketoglutarate a
five carbon keto acid take a look at the
structure of alpha ketoglutarate in the
upper right-hand portion of storyboard
eight panel a if you hold your finger
over the top two carbons of alpha
ketoglutarate you notice that the
residue is pyruvate so pyruvate plus an
acetyl functionality equals effectively
alpha ketoglutarate now take a look back
at the mechanism by which pyruvate is
oxidized by pyruvate pyruvate
dehydrogenase it's going to be a very
similar mechanism for the oxidation of
alpha ketoglutarate the product of the
alpha ketoglutarate dehydrogenase
reaction is succinylcholine if you look
at the structure of this molecule
succinylcholine an acid TOA with an
acetyl group put onto one end now let's
go back and look at the alpha
ketoglutarate from a different
perspective i want to make a point here
in that alpha ketoglutarate is an alpha
keto acid and if we were to replace its
keto group with an amino group you'd
convert this keto acid into the amino
acid glutamic acid as with most
enzymatic reactions involving such
nitrogen functionalities a paradoxical
pyridoxamine phosphate cofactor will be
needed to inter convert the alpha
ketoglutarate and glutamic acid so
glutamic acid can serve as a source of
alpha ketoglutarate if the cell is
starved for TCA cycle intermediates
alternatively alpha ketoglutarate can be
a
course for glutamic acid when a cell may
need amino acids for protein
biosynthesis now let's turn to panel B
where we'll start with succinylcholine
zma looking at the molecule of
succinylcholine
note that I've labeled each of the atoms
with a symbol the triangle n square were
from the original asset Eelco a molecule
that came in at the top of the pathway
the enzyme the processes section Yoko is
sectional coenzyme a synthetase as
joanne taught us synthetases are enzymes
that typically need a nucleotide in this
case the nucleotide involved is GDP in
mammalian systems or adp in bacterial
systems in the traditional clockwise
direction of the TCA cycle they're
phosphorylated to form GTP or ATP
respectively the molecule that you get
after the phosphorylation reaction and
the hydrolysis of the coenzyme a is
succinate a four carbon compound which
is also a dicarboxylic acid this
molecule is perfectly symmetrical and
can tumble in three-dimensional space
the next enzyme in the pathway succinate
dehydrogenase cannot distinguish one arm
of its substrate succinate from the
other so if there were a radio label in
the acetyl co a at the beginning of the
pathway that radio label would become
scrambled at this point uniformly
distributed among the two carbons of the
two arms from this point onward in the
TCA cycle you will note that the label
denoted as the triangle and box is
scrambled as indicated by triangle
divided by 2 or box divided by 2 the
next enzyme in the pathway is succinate
dehydrogenase this is the only membrane
bound enzyme in the TCA cycle it is a
dehydrogenase and it uses flavin as a
cofactor to help remove electrons from
the succinate substrate flavin picks up
electrons from succinate converting fa d
to fadh2 in the mitochondrial membrane
the product of the reaction is the
alkane fumarate the enzyme fumarate adds
water to fumarate to form the alcohol
product malate
the hydroxyl group of the alcohol malate
is primed for oxidation by the next
enzyme in the pathway malate
dehydrogenase or mdh mdh oxidizes malate
which is an alcohol to a ketone the
ketone product is oxaloacetate the
hydride removed from malate is
transferred to nad plus to form NADH as
I mentioned the product of the overall
reaction is oxaloacetate and it's ketone
functionality is now primed for attacked
by the next molecule of acetyl co a
entering the TCA cycle as a final point
I've mentioned several times that
oxaloacetate is present at a very low
concentration only in the micromolar
range inside the mitochondria of a
mammalian cell so it's always at rather
limiting concentration the cell has to
work very hard to preserve enough of the
oxaloacetate to enable the next cycle of
the TCA cycle that is the acquisition of
the next acetyl coenzyme a group one of
the ways that the cell can generate
oxaloacetate is by deamination or trans
emanation of aspartic acid to the keto
acid oxaloacetate we typically have
plenty of aspartic acid in this PLP
mediated reaction helps to maintain a
critical level of oxaloacetate I want to
return to storyboard 7 to make some
comments about the importance of pro
chirality in some enzymatic reactions
this short interlude will help explain
how to track a radial label in a TCA
cycle intermediate as that intermediate
progresses through the TCA cycle as you
will note at first glance the label does
some unexpected things but at the end of
the day the fact that the label does
surprising things helped early
biochemists figure out mechanistically
how several enzymes work in concert
during the linear steps of a pathway
we're going to look at storyboard seven
eight and nine starting with the
chemical reaction at the bottom right of
storyboard seven panel D this is the
chemical reaction that's catalyzed by
citrate synthase you'll notice that I've
highlighted the two carbons with either
a triangle or a box
as we have seen the nucleophile on
acetyl co a attacks the electro positive
carbon of the carbonyl functionality of
oxaloacetate the carbonyl functionality
is a flat sp2 hybridized center so if
this were a typical organic chemical
reaction the electrophile could come in
from either the top or the bottom and
you get two different stereochemistry
Xin the product that is the citrate at
the very bottom would have equally
labeled SOT alarms at the top and bottom
of the molecule as I've drawn it you
would have a delta divided by 2 for the
blue methylene group in a box R square
divided by 2 for the red carboxylate
group in each of the 2 SOT alarms again
these arms are at the bottom and top of
the molecule as drawn in the lower right
of panel D you'll note however that only
the top s2 teal group was citrate has
the labels initially the observation
that only the top arm acquired label was
a puzzle to early biochemist one way to
think about the citrate synthase
reaction is to think about the
oxaloacetate laying on the surface of
the citrate synthase enzyme now imagine
that the enzyme precludes or blocks
access to the carbonyl from the bottom
and allows access only to the top giving
rise to only one stereochemical outcome
the one that I've shown in the citrate
to the right now move ahead to the
storyboard number nine panel B this
panel shows a more cartoon like
representation of the molecule of
citrate you can see the SOT alarm on the
top the pro s armed as having the labels
and the pro are armed the one that came
from oxaloacetate at the bottom is label
free so while the pro R and pro s arms
are chemically identical they're going
to be handled by the next enzyme in the
series a connotates
as being chemically different from one
another all biochemistry is going to be
occurring on the pro our arm that is the
arm that came in from oxaloacetate and
not the arm that came in brass
- with acetyl coenzyme a in the bottom
right of panel being have sketched out
an imaginary active site for the Econo
taze enzyme I show a base picking up a
proton from the pro R arm of the citrate
molecule and you can see the elimination
of the water molecule from the 3 carbon
so despite the fact that the citrate
molecule is chemically symmetrical a
connotates the next enzyme in the
reaction series is able to distinguish
between the pro R and the pro s arms at
this point I want you to look back at
storybird 8 panel a look once again at
the citrate that is at the upper
left-hand corner of storyboard number 8
let's imagine that the Econo taste
chemistry has happened on the pro s arm
that is the one in the box keep in mind
that is experiments have shown that this
does not happen this is just a
hypothetical scenario in this
hypothetical case the hydroxyl group
would end up on the number two carbon
the one with the blue triangle you have
to draw it out but if you trace this
molecule in which the chemistry happened
on the pro s arm all the way around to
alpha ketoglutarate you would find out
that the alpha ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase would liberate co2 from
the carboxylate that has the red box on
it this is in contrast to the molecule
succinate that appears on storyboard
eight panel b succinate is another
symmetrical molecule but for some reason
succinate dehydrogenase cannot
distinguish between the two SOT alarms
because the enzyme is unable to
distinguish the two arms in this case
unlike that of ikana tazed the radio
label would become scrambled the reason
that I'm belaboring this point is
because one of the ways that biochemists
work out the chemical reactions involved
in a biochemical pathways by putting in
some kind of labelled molecule it could
be a radio label or heavy isotope and
then they trace the position of the
label in the molecule as you move from
molecule to molecule along the pathway
so label tracer studies are ones that
are absolutely central to
all of Biochemistry and as I mentioned
earlier you'll get lots of experience on
the problem sets in using labels to work
out the details of a pathway before
leaving the TCA cycle there are a couple
of big picture points that I want to
make you put in two carbons as asset
Eelco a deposit them into oxaloacetate
to form citrate a six carbon compound
and then in the cycle you lose two
carbons as carbon dioxide that means
that there's no loss or gain of carbon
in the cycle if you had just one
molecule of oxaloacetate you'd be able
to complete the TCA cycle what happens
however when the cell in isn't is in and
let's say quote-unquote energy needed
situation where it needs to buff up this
cycle that is increased the number of
molecules cycling to be able to
accommodate the processing of more and
more molecules of acetyl co a those
molecules of acetic OE might flood in
from carbohydrate metabolism or as we'll
see later from catabolism of lipids
let's look at panel a of storyboard 11
as shown in this figure one way to
accomplish increasing the carbon content
of the TCA cycle is to take an amino
acid such as glutamate and remove its
amino group to form alpha ketoglutarate
note that if you increase the
concentration of any one molecule in the
TCA cycle for example alpha
ketoglutarate you're effectively
increasing the concentrations of all
molecules in the cycle because it's a
cycle many of the molecules are in
equilibrium with one another going
clockwise around the TCA cycle from
alpha ketoglutarate we come to
succinylcholine Eelco a is an entry
point into the TCA cycle from odd chain
fatty acids and certain amino acids such
as methionine so these molecules can
give rise to succinylcholine self will
then increase the concentration of all
molecules in the TCA cycle our third
primary input point is at oxaloacetate
it involves aspartic acid being emanated
into oxaloacetate this is a very common
way to increase the amount of
oxaloacetate available for the TCA cycle
this reaction can dramatically increase
the rate of processing of molecules by
the TCA cycle finally there's an enzyme
we'll look at later called pyruvate
carboxylase or PC which can take
pyruvate in the mitochondrion add co2 to
it in form oxaloacetate we're going to
come to this enzyme later when we talk
about carboxylase enzymes as a class
this is an important enzyme in the
pathway of gluconeogenesis so overall I
think you can see that there are several
ways that a cell can increase the
overall concentration of the
intermediates of the TCA cycle
increasing any one intermediate
increases all of them and that will
increase the rate by which asset alkaway
molecules can be processed ultimately to
generate energy the general word
describing this puffing up of the TCA
cycle is an applause Asst which comes
from the Greek word filling up